I'm reinvesting the business are you  reinvesting or do you just make no  profit big difference I think that  earlier on I advise most business owners  to take as much money out of the company  as they can it teaches Good Financial  hygiene I'm a big believer in like set  the number that needs to be in the bank  account every month drain it to that and  then do that as many times as you can  for me once I had a certain amount of  material wealth that I didn't have to  worry about any personal needs for good  that number is different for everyone at  that point it makes more sense to then  truly reinvest because now you've  learned all the habits that actually  make money and take that Capital because  now you've gotten better at allocating  capital and then you can think in terms  of return on that allocation then sure  like you can compound the wealth faster  than the s p can